ce gouvernement il s'est construit sur
une coalition entre la ligue du nord et
le mouvement 5 étoiles c'est justement
ce principe de coalition d'alliance que
vous cherchez à atteindre vous aussi en
france c'est une alliance et plusieurs
choses c'est la possibilité de s'allier
avec des mouvements politiques la
possibilité d'attirer soit des gens qui
viennent d'autres mouvements politiques
ou la possibilité d'attirer soit des
gens qui viennent de la société civile
c'est ce qu'a fait main de mâcon il
s'est allié au modem un parti politique
il a rallié à lui des gens qui venaient
du ps et des républicains et puis il
s'est ouvert à la société civile le
hawaii et je trouve que c'est
intéressant
elle nous on souhaite pouvoir s'allier
avec des mouvements politiques si eux
mêmes le souhaitent ils sont pas très
nombreux aujourd'hui dans la sur la
carte électorale française mais on
souhaite attirer à nous les gens qui
viennent de gauche et droite et puis des
gens de la société c'est pour ça que
vous appelez désormais rassemblement
national c'est ça est ce que le ce
nouveau nom prend auprès des militants
que vous rencontrez dans votre
circonscription est ce que ça ça
fonctionne
il va vouloir l'installer ça fait quinze
jours trois semaines
donc on va prendre le temps de
l'installer puis les élections
européennes seront je crois un bon
moment et une bonne opportunité pour
installer ce rassemblement des
françaises et des français qui croient
que la nation ça vaut encore quelque
chose que le rôle de l'état
il est important contrairement à ces des
régulateurs que sont les amis des
venelles macron justement sur ce
rassemblement marine le pen plaide elle
pour le rassemblement de tous les
patriotes de tous bords qui comprit venu
de la gauche
marion maréchal à une stratégie
différente puisqu'elle parle d'union des
droites à son sujet vous avez des démos
dans le point
il ya quelques jours vous dites chez
elles les appétits personnels parce
parfois avant les enjeux collectifs
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire qu'on est
enfin il faut repréciser les choses je
parlais de ses appétits personnels
intellectuelle d'accord voilà
marion maréchal mène un chemin que je
trouve tout à fait louable et courageuse
de créer une entreprise de faire de la
méta politique c'est-à-dire de forme et
d'irriguer les cerveaux de nos idées et
on en a forcément besoin et puis il ya
ceux qui continuent le combat électoral
derrière marine le pen aujourd'hui donc
moi je pense qu'on a besoin des deux
d'ailleurs on gagne d'abord dans les
têtes avant de gagner dans les urnes
mais pour gagner dans les urnes il faut
des gens sur le terrain et marine le pen
et les élus du rassemblement national en
font partie donc on a besoin des deux je
pense qu'il faut pas se limiter à
l'union des droites
c'est un peu restrictif bien sûr tu
feras cueillir les gens de droite moi je
viens de l'ump j'en suis l'exemple il
faut accueillir les gens de droite qui
veulent nous rejoindre mais notre
discours est bien il se destine aussi
aux gens venus de la gauche aux gens
qu'ils ont été trahis pendant de tant
d'années qui sont attachés au rôle de
l'état à la république à ses valeurs à
la capacité que la france et a protégé
les siens oui notre discours il se
destine à tous